nancy pelosi ya despegó la visita
relámpago de la presidenta de la cámara
de representantes estadounidense a
taiwán termino pero las turbulencias no
han hecho más que empezar
dentro de taiwán la ciudadanía vivió
dividida el evento
ahora que pelosi ha satisfecho sus
ambiciones personales ya ha dejado
taiwán veremos las consecuencias que
tendremos que sufrir
creo que es un evento histórico
importante su visita nos abrirá puertas
diplomáticas
mientras tanto las autoridades
taiwanesas reportaron un aumento
exponencial de los ciberataques en todas
las instituciones públicas y alrededor
de la isla el ejército chino mantiene
sus operaciones militares para
recordarle al mundo que según beijing
taiwán forma parte de su territorio
nacional un mundo que no ha tenido prisa
para respaldar a eeuu
la secretaria general de las naciones
unidas fue escueta pero clara
la única cosa que diré es que la
política de las naciones unidas es que
nos guiamos por la resolución 27 58 de
la asamblea general de 1971 de una sola
china' externan sin ser ni one on one
chain
los gobiernos de irán nicaragua y rusia
defendieron que las tensiones entre
taiwán y china continental son asuntos
internos
y esto no es una política dirigida a
apoyar libertades y democracias efímeras
y es pura provocación y usted rockers
camboya es ahora el escenario de un
nuevo cara a cara entre beijing y
washington para la reunión de ministros
de exteriores de la asean la cumbre de
países del sudeste asiático que ahora
deberán reabrir caminos diplomáticos
para rebajar las tensiones en la región